did you ever feel like sort of compelled
like in your later years after you kind
of created Wet Hot American Summer and
all these different things in the state
and did you ever feel like compelled to
be weird or quirky or off just so you
almost like you couldn't really truly be
you you're trying to be someone else as
growing up does that make sense so yes
it makes total sense a great question
and the answer is not really it's
usually the opposite it's usually I'm
trying to do or or I'm in a place where
I'm assigned to do something and I'm
naturally looking to push it weirder and
I have to stop that because it's not
what we're doing you know right whether
I'm directing a regular TV show or
something you know and uh we're or we're
struggling with a script moment I'm like
well you know if we were doing this like
in a vacuum I would say let's have him
you know turn around and jump in a pool
of water here or something weird and and
but I'm like I know we can't do that so
let's you know that always comes to you
let's do the harder way right
um but no I luckily I don't think the
the demand for my brand is so uh
actually uh existent that people are
like you've got to be weird and I feel
pressure to be right you know in any way
more
off than I am and I'm not that off I'm
just like a dude yeah you are dude but
do you ever think like some people might
think I guess Studios would think oh
it's a risk because it's that certain
brand and we don't know if that's gonna
either hit or not it's too much of a
risk we want something more mainstream
well I feel like I've consistently my
whole career not gotten work because
people are like oh he can only do that
like his his stuff is funny but it's too
weird for us you know and and you're
like no I can do the other side I did
Role Models I do I've used exactly and
also I can I've I've done the range of
things over time and uh you know I can
handle you know as a director had
sometimes been frustrated because I've
I've done such a wide variety of styles
and levels and and uh media and
um as you said the brand can have
um a double edge to it and people like
oh he's the guy who just does like
really goofy dumb things and so we have
this thing that we have real feeling
about and it matters to us so there's no
way he could handle that yeah I'm like
do you just feel like you have to fight
more these days for something you're
passionate about or do you and you you
still obviously write your own stuff
yes I do I I've always generated my own
stuff
um but I also do feel like yeah I think
just the natural uh progression and
getting older and I'm not in the I'm not
in that I'm not young anymore and I'm a
middle-aged white guy in Hollywood and I
I definitely have to
I feel like I have to work harder to get
heard and that's fine but you know
another cool thing is you think you
think looking at your resume and looking
at the people who follow you looking at
the people who want to be in your movies
who are consistently cast in your movies
like The Paul rudds and all these other
names that you see these big names they
obviously love you and love your mind
and want to work with you yeah so that
should excite Studios yeah